Pour 1 monde sans patron ni frontière, urgence,
révolution !
Le nouveau parti anticapitaliste sera
présent aux élections
européennes de juin prochain
avec 1 liste conduite par Selma la Bible,
28 ans, conductrice de bus égale qui rentre, 48 ans,
syndicaliste à la poste.
Nous présentons 1 liste de
travailleuses et de travailleurs
du public comme du privé,
de jeunes étudiants ou salariés
pour mettre en avant les
priorités de celles et ceux qui font tourner la société,
c'est nous qui travaillons,
c'est nous qui décidons.
Nous avons
besoin de salaire décent pour vivre et pas seulement
survivre. €400 de plus pour tous et toutes,
et pas 1 salaire, pas 1 pension,
pas 1 revenu social inférieur à €2.000 net.
Pas question de subir l'ostérité alors que les
profits des capitalistes sont au plus haut.
Le capitalisme porte en lui la guerre
comme la nuit porte l'orage.
Quand il s'agit de gaver d'argent
les industries de l'armement,
le gouvernement ne compte pas ses sous.
Les marchands d'armes
français sont maintenant sur la 2e marche de spodium
sanglant, juste derrière les États-Unis.
Les discours guerriers de Macron
n'ont pas pour but d'aider les peuples ukrainiens
mais de vendre
toujours plus d'armes aux dirigeants ukrainiens,
comme ils en vont à bien d'autres pays
tel que l'Égypte pour réprimer sa propre population
ou à l'état d'Israël pour massacrer les civils de Gaza.
Courant derrière l'extrême droite,
Macron reprend 1 grande partie de son programme.
Ils essaient de nous faire croire que ce sont les.
Travailleurs et les travailleuses qui n'auraient pas
la bonne couleur de peau
ou les bons papiers
et qui sont responsables de tous les mots,
nous n'avons rien à gagner
dans ce duel annoncé entre les listes de Macron
et celle de barbela Le Pen.
Nous avons en revanche tout à gagner dans des luttes
collective
qui se donnent les moyens de renverser l'ordre établi.
Le programme qu'on défend,
c'est 1 programme de lutte,
ils ont des milliards,
nous sommes des 1.000.000.
Urgences révolution.